what did you do that I can't even deal
with this
[Music]
hi it's Miranda Lambert today I'm doing
an interview with rescue puppies as you
can see they're all up for adoption by
the way my dog stitute a lot of
interesting things the very only Louie
Vuitton purse I've ever owned was given
to me and it lost its handles really
quickly so I gave up on nothing my dogs
are more important spin-up saying about
realest high club right with another
artist there's a lot I think but I'm a
huge fan and Beyonce's probably every
girl's answer would be Beyonce have you
ever mixed drink is he does vodka and
Lefroy I don't have a favorite song or
album because they're all my babies
they're like my dogs but I really
enjoyed the process of this last record
I did called the weight of these wings
because I took my time on it and spent
over a year riding for it and I really
got to sort of explore my songwriting in
a different way than I ever had before
I'm a huge Audioslave fans I'd say that
was pretty different than the rest of
the sewol my iPod old-school
favorite place to eat in Nashville it's
actually a bar it's called winners cause
winners and losers over my hangout spots
in Midtown but they have delicious
chicken tenders and awesome system real
dis inspired me to start it
my passion for dogs and rescue dogs and
mutts if you are not a dog lover yet you
should become one and I would say adopt
don't shop love a shelter pets
[Music]